[Musique]
261 mètres de long pour plus de 40 000
tonnes le porte-avion Charles de Gaulle
est le plus imposant navire de guerre
française
en mars il quittait la rade de Toulon
pour son premier déploie opérationnel
après 18 mois de travaux changements du
combustible nucléaire refonte du
centrales opération et des ateliers
moteurs rénovation des radars et du
système de catapultage passage à l'air
du numérique l'arrêt technique a aussi
permis de finaliser les transformations
liées au 100% rafales et à l'arrivée de
l'hélicoptère Caïman marine au total 4
millions d'heures de travail pour un
budget d'un milliard 300 millions
d'euros
imaginez à la fin des années 80 le
navire a été repensé pour faire face aux
menaces futures et abrite tous les
équipements nécessaires au combat
moderne ces derniers mois les marins ont
repris possession du bâtiment et
apprivoisaient les innovations dans ce
numéro le journal de la défense vous
embarque sur ce géant des mers pour
découvrir les nouveautés et comprendre
leur impact sur les métiers du bord et
capacité opérationnelles du porte-avion
préparez-vous à intégrer les coulisses
du Charles de Gaulle armés par 1900
marins
en approche à une vitesse de 250 km/h le
pilote doit viser une zone grande comme
un terrain de tennis et accrocher l'un
des trois brins d'arrêt pour s'arrêter
à la radio les officiers d’approntage
ces pilotes chevronnés le guide dans sa
manœuvre
[Musique]
c'est là où les officiers la montage
observent les appontage pour la sécurité
des avions on a mis à neuf tous nos
indicateurs
le l'outil principal c'est le miroir
d'appontage c'est donc le dispositif
lumineux dont on se servent les pilotes
pour juger de leurs pentes et impacter
au bon endroit et on a acheté donc sur
étagère d'un miroir américain qui a une
technologie différente et donc il y a
modifié notre notre façon de faire et
qui a amené des équipements nouveaux sur
la plateforme pour le pour le régler
c'est le nouvel optique d'apontage notre
rôle au quotidien c'est de s'assurer dès
le matin que l'installation est paraît
pour recevoir des avions et puis à
échéance faire les maintenance
préventives
on peut être amené à intervenir en cas
d'avari donc il faut bien connaître
l'installation puisqu'on a des délais
qui sont assez courts pour intervenir à
remplacer des pièces dans le système
un local dédié aux réglage et à
l'entretien du nouveau miroir
d'appontage a été créé durant les
travaux le passage de la mécanique à
l'électronique facilite le travail des
électriciens
qui nous a bien fait évoluer dans notre
travail de tous les jours cet écran là
qui nous permet d'avoir un report des
alarmes en direct en instantané et qui
nous fait gagner beaucoup de temps sur
les interventions et sur les maintenance
correctives c'est un bon technologique
pour nous donc si on y gagne en
fiabilité du système on y gagne aussi en
termes de formation et de compétences de
notre personnel
[Musique]
l'objectif il est multiple il est
poursuivre la fiabilisation technique du
bâtiment qui après plus de 2 ans d'arrêt
a besoin d'un peu de temps en mer pour
pouvoir reprendre ses marques c'est de
la mécanique c'est des équipements
complexes qui ont besoin de tourner
parfaitement fiable c'est également
permettre au marin de redéler leur
savoir-faire et c'est également
permettre aux marins d'acquérir des
nouveaux savoir-faire liés aux nouveaux
équipements qui ont été mis en place à
bord du porte-avion dans le cadre de sa
rénovation à midi c'est ce que j'appelle
le Charles de Gaulle 2.0
nous avons réorganisé le bateau de telle
manière que la prise en compte de la
cyberdéfense soit effectivement une
réalité avec des nouvelles compétences
et une densification de l'organisation
dans ce domaine là avec plus de marins
pour pouvoir nous défendre face à des
potentiels
et on a
ça nous a également permis d'accueillir
des nouveaux radars qui vont permettre
au Charles de Gaulle d'avoir un suivi de
la situation avec une portée bien plus
lointaine plus haut plus loin une des
nouvelles arrivées au centrales
opération c'est la tape tactique par
rapport aux anciennes elle est beaucoup
plus moderne dans le sens où on n'a pas
besoin d'avoir un opérateur qui vient
travailler à la main dessus elle nous
permet de voir bien plus loin et elle
permet de recevoir en permanence et de
visualiser les informations de nos
pistes à nous mais également de toutes
celles que nous recevons de nos amis
français ou de nos amis alliés à court
échelle pour moi en tant que chez lutte
anti navire du bord ça va me permettre
de voir très rapidement où sont les
frégatives nous entourent où est mon
hélicoptère où sont mes aéronef et
qu'est-ce quelles sont les infos qui
sont en mesure de me donner tout de
suite et ça c'est une vraie révolution
technologique
cette mise en réseau de tous ces rafales
en même temps en vol avec le Hokage avec
les frégates avec le porte-avion quand
le groupe aéronaval beaucoup plus
performant dans l'analyse de la
situation tactique autour de lui et dans
sa capacité à projeter la puissance avec
le retrait du Super Étendard modernisé
en 2016 seuls les avions de chasse
raffalmarine volent aujourd'hui sur le
porte-avion
l'avantage d'être passé à un seul type
de chasseur c'est à dire le Rafale on
gagne en puissance le projection parce
que la capacité d'emports d'un Rafale
est équivalente
à entre deux et trois super étendards
donc on gagne en capacité de projection
d'armement on gagne aussi en allonge le
Rafale va plus loin il est capable de
voler plus longtemps on gagne aussi en
capacité de mise en oeuvre à bord du
porte-avion c'est à dire que si les
conditions météorologiques sont un peu
plus compliquées c'est à dire que la mer
bouche plus qui fait plus chaud et bien
le Rafale est capable d'être catapulté
et d'apponter à bord on va dire dans des
conditions plus extrêmes
[Musique]
saut avec le Rafale et impressionnant à
les performances du Rafale sont
incomparables par rapport à ceux du père
étendard on a une puissance une
manœuvrabilité qui est un calculable
disons qu'on avait affaire avec le Super
Étendard à un avion qu'il fallait un
petit peu bichonner avec lequel il
fallait être prudent pour le Rafale on
peut être on peut se fier complètement à
la machine et arriver à faire des
évolutions incroyables pour ma part il y
a un aspect coeur j'étais assez attaché
à l'avion j'ai fait de l'essentiel de ma
carrière là-dessus parce que je viens à
peine de passer sur un fan donc j'ai
encore un attachement un peu un peu
sentimental à la machine mais je suis
obligé de d'être convaincu par les
performances du Rafale le passage autour
rafale fait grimper la capacité de
porte-avion de 24 à 30 rafales marines
un avion peut décoller toutes les 30
secondes sur le pont d'envol tout est
millimétré pour assurer la sécurité des
vols par les chiens jaunes sous leurs
ordres en bleu les poneys entre chaque
mouvement aviation c'est matelot du pont
d'envol doivent immobiliser les aéronefs
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
dans le hangar un engin téléguidé la
moto toc attire notre caméra
ça nous permet de verrouiller le
frein
ultra avant de l'aéronef le soulever
pour ensuite pouvoir le manipuler et
pouvoir le guider pouvoir ensuite le
placer proprement c'est plus précis donc
pour travailler dans le hangar c'est
ça c'est restreint pour la place du coup
avec ça c'est plus pratique par rapport
au tracteur mais c'est assez sensible en
fait quand on guide
faut pas mettre trop de force dans
l'avion n'aura pas par assez rapidement
vous devez plus que le directeur nous
dit après
le hangar c'est un peu le poumon du
porte-avion une usine aéronautique où ça
fait un jour et nuit 300 techniciens
pour préparer les décollages et
entretenir les aéronefs
grâce à la rotation des équipes 24
heures sur 24 plus de 90% des rafales
sont en permanence prêt à voler
[Musique]
donc là je suis en train de dépanner un
poste radio on va procéder à l'échange
vionique sur rafale c'est passé de une
deux chevaux et une grosse BMW en fait
c'est beaucoup plus poussé en
technologie cet avion il y a beaucoup
plus de système sont un peu plus
compliqué à dépanner cet avion là et
géré par un ordinateur central qui va
nous dire où sont les fans que le Super
Étendard en fait il y avait juste les
fans que nous citer le pilote et après
c'était à nous avec notre expérience de
trouver d'où venait la panne
[Musique]
classique et alimentaire à bord il
existe une usine de traitement de
déchets un lieu stratégique puisque près
de 90% des ordures plastiques bois
carton métaux léger sont acheminés ici
regardez ça jusqu'à quand on arrive à
quelle heure
plastique on a différentes machines donc
de broyeur compacteur donc qui nous
permettent donc de broyer les déchets de
dissouillés et qui nous permettent
également de les compacter pour gagner
en place et après être stocké dans un
frigo et éviter en fait les les
émanations de gaz donc pouvoir avoir une
autonomie de 12 jours au maximum avant
de réclamer un
derrière vous vous avez donc broyeur
pulpteur qui est installé durant que
durant durant la T donc la résultante du
broyeur pulper en fait c'est ce que vous
voyez ici dans la poubelle donc de la
pulpe alimentaire et donc ici on a une
pulpe sèche qu'on va pouvoir jeter en
fait via le plus alimentaire et ce soir
on donnera manger au poisson
les déchets alimentaires sont stockés
dans un premier temps au frigo puisque
nous n'avons pas l'autorisation de
l'aviar vidanger en fait l'alimentaire
en permanence il y a une raison à cela
c'est que les avions quand ils
approntent ils ont besoin en fait
d'avoir une vue claire et si
effectivement on jette de l'alimentaire
ça amène les oiseaux sur place donc il y
a un gros risque sécurité pour les
avions
et si on arrive sur la zone de
traitement de déchets non souillé donc
c'est essentiellement du cartonnage on
va se contenter de les compacter de les
ficeler et de les stocker dans un local
sec avant le RAM
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
en fait on est en train de changer les
vessies sur les gilets de survie et les
composants qui à l'intérieur les plus
récides siffler miroir et comme nous
avons changé la vessie nous devons
remettre après ces composants de
réinstaller sur la sur la vessie faire
attention à ne pas avec l'aiguille
percer la vessie voilà on prend notre
temps on fait attention on suit bien la
doc et on va pas trop vite charger
d'équiper les avions en munitions les
booms doivent aussi veiller au bon état
des équipements de survie combinaison
radeau Gillette sauvetage et nouveau
paquetage de survie du caïman marine
et pour vérifier le bon fonctionnement
des tenues de vol les pilotes sont mis à
contribution en fait on est en train de
tester et combinaisons étanche
comportent leur des vols sur les bases
donc nous à Lorient lambioué on a
mannequin habituellement qui peut perdre
de tester cette conduite et lorsqu'on
est aborde il y a pas de mannequins
disponible donc c'est nous les Minecraft
ils vont vérifier le poids initialement
avant qu'on soit immergé dans l'eau et
on doit rester entre 20 et 30 minutes
dans l'eau et à partir de là il refond
une mesure à l'issue et on voit si l'eau
est entré dans la combinaison quoi donc
si elle est pleinement étanche
parce que j'ai fait parce que j'ai fait
comme sur tous les bâtiments de la
Marine l'équipage du Charles est réglé à
leur zoulou celle du fuseau horaire
universel elle a tombé de la nuit la
lumière passe au rouge pour habituer
l’œil à l'obscurité une façon de réguler
l'horloge biologique des marins
dans les coursives une équipe envoie les
palettes pour le ravitaillement à la mer
donc là nous allons procéder à
ravitaillement à la mer donc c'est une
opération qui consiste à renvoyer du
matériel sur le pétrolier ravitailleur
donc des déchets et des pièces
mécaniques
usagées comme jamais préparées et dans
l'autre sens le Var donc qui est avec
nous aujourd'hui va nous renvoyer du
matériel pour réparer les avions pour
assurer la maintenance du bord et
également des vivre pour assurer la
nourriture pour l'équivalent
ravitaillement la mer dure en moyenne
entre 3 et 4 heures aujourd'hui on est
sur environ 35 allées de déchets de 200
kg donc 7 tonnes de déchets
quand on est en mission on tourne sur un
cycle de ravitaillement de entre 8 et 10
jours de manière à pouvoir garder à une
autonomie maximale en cas d'opération
[Musique]
carré officier araignée tous les regards
sont figés sur le poste de télévision
pour le tournoi des 6 nations le rugby
c'est une institution dans la marine et
ce soir pas question de rater le crunch
France Angleterre
quelques Pomps plus hauts l'équipage
profite de la salle de distraction le
seul moyen on peut se détendre en fait
c'est ici c'est là qu'on réunit
quasiment plein de gens qu'on connaît
pas mais vous êtes d'abord une semaine
qu'on s'est pas vu mais c'est comme ça
on discute un peu et puis on parle aussi
un peu de tout quoi la famille comment
ça se passe parce que c'est dur qu'on a
pas mis surtout sur le porte-avion c'est
particulier parce que très peu d'escale
du coup c'est là qu'on a besoin d'avoir
un soutien aussi des collègues en disant
que on n'est pas les seuls dans le cas
là et puis du coup on se soutient
mutuellement
[Musique]
à l'aube inspection du pont d'envol les
marins appellent cela la cueillette à
petit pas de l'avant vers l'arrière du
bateau il traque tout débris pour parer
au moindre incident
comme chaque matin les chefs de services
procèdent à la revue des troupes
pour le porte-avions pas de branle-bas
pour réveiller l'équipage il y a une
raison à cela du technicien au pilote il
faut préserver le sommeil des équipes de
nuit
[Musique]
bonjour autre unité précieuse pour le
commandement le Service météorologique
et océanographique l'arrêt technique l'a
équipé d'un télémètre pour mesurer la
hauteur et l'extension des nuages et
d'un nouvel appareil de prévision et un
système historique de Météo France donc
c'est un outil qu'on a fait évoluer
durant durant la technique qui permet
d'automérer d'automatiser un maximum
toutes ce qui est processus de
récupération de données ce qui permet
finalement de au privilégier de se
centrer sur le cœur de métier qui est
d'étude du temps
nous sommes marins nous sommes sur un
bateau qui a des avions et donc qui est
extrêmement soumis aux conditions
météorologiques le premier rôle de la
météo c'est de dire évidemment le temps
qu'il va faire sachant qu'on ne maîtrise
pas par contre on peut maîtriser la
position du bateau donc c'est l'avantage
d'avoir une base d'aériennes flottante
et qui se déplace c'est que en fonction
des prévisions météo alors pas que
évidemment mais c'est un facteur qui
joue on est capable de positionner le
bateau à l'endroit qu'il faut pour
pouvoir mettre en œuvre l'aviation et
donc on étudie aussi les terrains des
terrains de destination mais pas que il
y a aussi tous les terrains de
dégagement ou déroutement qui a sur le
sur le trajet des avions donc finalement
on fait la météo marine sur la position
du porte-avion mais également sur une
zone bien plus vaste
[Musique]
dans les entrailles du porte-avion des
atomiciens veillent sur les deux
réacteurs nucléaires depuis leur salle
de contrôle pour information nous a
annoncé 10 catapultage à l'avant donc on
en a déjà eu un et en attendant 9 autres
au niveau des choux frits pendant la
technique l'opération principale ça a
été de recharger les coeurs nucléaires
donc on a déchargé les anciens coeurs et
on a rechargé les cœurs pour repartir
avec de l'énergie pour 10 ans
donc l'énergie nucléaire du Charles de
Gaulle s'est reproduire l'ensemble de
l'énergie du bateau donc à partir de des
deux chaufferies qu'on a à bord on
produit de la vapeur qui vient entraîner
des turbines qui font tourner les deux
hélices du bâtiment et également les
turbines qui produisent de l'électricité
pour le tout le bateau on produit
également la vapeur qui sert à
catapulter les avions du Charles de
Gaulle et enfin on participe également
la production d'eau de consommation
humaine et chaque jour 520 tonnes d'eau
de mer sont désalinisés
qu'on a six machines à laver cinq
sèche-linge donc on a trois machines à
laver qui ont été changées durant latte
dernier
donc les gens là ont fini de venir
déposer la fin de la fin de dépose du
linge
est à 14 heures
donc il reste tout ça après été donc
pour la pour la journée donc là
honnêtement je pense pas qu'ils aient
terminé avant un bon 3 heures du matin
encore une fois
merci bon après-midi merci à vous aussi
[Musique]
autre pan de ce chantier titanesque le
réaménagement les ateliers moteurs pour
poursuivre le passage au 100% rafale il
faut savoir qu'ici avant c'était une ère
qui était réservée au moteur des supers
étendards mais depuis le passage autour
rafale et donc la dernière hyper on
installe ici une nouvelle aire de visite
afin de pouvoir retravailler sur trois
moteurs simultanément trois heures donc
un terme modulaire
on passe d'une maintenance d'une
ancienne génération une technologie qui
est beaucoup plus propre beaucoup plus
utilisable qui est mieux pensé qui a été
conçu pour optimiser les temps de
démontage et remontage et ce qui
contribue à optimiser la disponibilité
des avions il a fallu se reconvertir il
faut repasser par des stages
d'adaptation se former c'est une remise
en question pour les personnel aussi un
personnel composé de 24 techniciens dont
la majorité est issue du service
industriel aéronautique de Landivisiau
c'est entre leurs mains expertes que
passe le M88 moteur du Rafale Marine
sans moteur qui se compose plusieurs
modules en tranches comme ça et donc on
va les retirer un par un pour pouvoir
avancer en fonction du chantier qu'on a
pour aller chercher le module qui nous
intéresse alors là actuellement je suis
en train de effectuer un contrôle visuel
à l'aide d'une binoculaire en fait c'est
une sorte de deux grosses loupe parce
que je vais pouvoir contrôler les
moindres imperfections au niveau de la
pièce le Tour Eiffel a changé
littéralement les méthodes de
maintenance braque au niveau du moteur
sa conception est complètement
différente ça a amené à des nouvelles
méthodes de travail avec des nouveaux
outils une précision un peu plus sacrée
au niveau du travail une autre rapidité
la particularité de cet atelier c'est
qu'il dispose d'un banc décès moteur
embarqué en y fixant un M88 de 900 kg
les techniciens peuvent tester sa
puissance son étanchéité et effectuer
des diagnostics
dans le but en fait c'est de trouver les
pannes ici pour pas que qu'on livre en
moteur c'est pas là se trouvait en
flottement
[Musique]
une demi-heure s'il vous plaît
merci
là je viens d'appeler le bureau
technique aviation qui va demander
l'autorisation à la passerelle savoir si
au niveau des activités
du bateau en lui-même ça ne pose pas de
problème que je tourne parce qu'on va
condamner par exemple la plage arrière
pour le bruit et toutes les nuisances
que ça peut entraîner par exemple si on
remore une bouée on peut pas tourner
s'il y a des exercices de tir plage
arrière on peut pas tourner on va
turbulences d'air chaud à l'arrière du
bâtiment donc ça ça peut perturber les
avantages activer marge démarreur
c'est parti
dernier arrivé du groupe aérien embarqué
le caïman marine sa présence à bord
renforce encore les capacités
opérationnelles du bâtiment un
hélicoptère polyvalent et d'une
autonomie en vol de 3h et puis le
porte-avion les missions que le Caïman
est à même d'effectuer c'est bien sûr
tout ce qui est lutte anti navire lutte
au-dessus de la surface le Cayman est
également en mesure d'effectuer ce qu'on
appelle de la lutte anti sous-marine on
est également en mesure de faire des
missions ce qu'on appelle force
protection et protéger les bâtiments qui
transitent dans des zones sensibles en
plus de cela avec ses capacités
logistiques dues à sa grandeur la
capacité d'emports on serait en mesure
si un Rafale et en panne sur un terrain
de lui amener un moteur pour le réparer
[Musique]
au pont 7 les pompiers sont en alerte le
porte-avion vient de subir une attaque
donc on a été touché par des missiles
sur baboret sur tribord les pompiers de
la zone interviennent au niveau du pont
évacuer les blessés quand il y en a
mettre les bords de côté et donc il y a
un peu à maîtriser donc le but de
l'exercice c'est d'entraîner ce
personnel à acquérir des réflexes de
jour où ça se produit avec les équipes
qui se puissent intervenir
le feu constitue un danger redoutable
sur un navire c'est la raison pour
laquelle chaque marin embarqué est formé
à la lutte anti-incendie feu voit d'eau
ou attaque en face de remontée en
puissance l'équipage est sans cesse
évaluer sur sa capacité à réagir face à
tous types de sinistre
33 pilotes formés un chiffre qui englobe
les qualifications à la pontage jour et
nuit et les transformations des pilotes
habituées à voler sur d'autres appareils
que le Rafale Marine
sur le Rafale et bon on est à la merci
de la catapulte donc on se laisse faire
et on attend que ça sorte de pompe pour
récupérer la viande
il y a deux phases il faut arriver à
séquencer d'abord les procédures de pont
pour le catapultage en sécurité puis la
partie de la mission tactique et enfin
le retour où il faut rester quand même
concentré
se concentrer de technologie et de
savoir-faire permettent aux porte-avions
et aux groupes aéronaval de rester des
outils stratégiques de premier plan les
conflits de demain seront sans doute de
plus en plus en mer porte-avions à son
groupe aéronavale sont des outils par
essence de maîtrise des espaces
arboratives qui permettront
inévitablement de pouvoir assurer la
défense des intérêts vitaux la France en
rénovant le porte-avion en rénovant
aussi les éléments qui constituent le
groupe aéronaval je pense à la frame je
pense au Barracuda futur sous-marin qui
va intégrer bientôt le groupe en aval ou
aussi à tout un modernisation
progressive étape par étape du Rafale et
bien le groupe aéronaval garde toute sa
pertinence et toute sa puissance de feu
adapté aux menaces actuelles aux menaces
modernes et donc permet à la France de
garder un outil militaire extrêmement
crédible et donc avec un poids politique
très fort et notamment lorsque la France
veut marquer sa volonté d'intervenir
dans un théâtre et bien l'envoi d'un
nous avions est souvent un moyen
d'exprimer cette volonté
dans le cadre de la mission Clémenceau
le Charles de Gaulle est aujourd'hui
déployé au Levant malgré la chute de ces
derniers bastions les opérations
militaires se poursuivent contre daesh
escorté par des bâtiments alliés
européens et américains il sillonnera
l'océan Indien jusqu'au mois de juillet
fin 2018 le ministère des armées lançait
un programme d'études sur son successeur
d'ici là beaucoup d'eau aura encore
glissé sur les trappes du Charles remise
à neuf pour 20 ans